Speaker 1: but we saw Brandon Johnson win the
mayoral race in Chicago. We also saw this liberal
Supreme Court, Wisconsin Supreme Court candidate
win her race in Wisconsin, making Wisconsin now
have a left leaning Supreme Court for the first
time in 50 years. And Charlie Kirk recognizes
that result decreases their chances of being able
to win the White House in 24. He won't say why,
but obviously it's because they plan to cheat.
They plan to go to the Supreme Court of Wisconsin
to try to get the Wisconsin electoral votes
in 2024, whether or not their candidate gets
the most votes. Take a listen to this.
Speaker 2: Yesterday was not a good
day for you. Not only was Trump around, Wisconsin
was a blowout and there goes the Wisconsin Supreme
Court and it decreases our chance to be able to
win the White House in 2024. It's not impossible.
But we tried to warn people turning point
action was on the ground. We were knocking
on doors trying to raise money. The RNC nowhere
to be found. My yeah, that's why we tried to
do everything we could to get regime change done
at the RNC. They wouldn't be bothered. They were
too busy doing their things that they do, which is
nothing but pay themselves and. Take care of their
D.C. consultants and then Chicago. Not as if it.
You know, I was in a going in a hopeful direction,
decided to elect an outright Marxist.
Marxist is going to become mayor of Chicago.
Speaker 1: He's not a marxist. But let's focus
in on the Supreme Court piece of this. The only
way they can win is cheating and overturning the
will of the voters. He's saying the quiet part
out loud. He is saying, Now, now I'll give you
hit. I know he doesn't mean to be saying this,
but what he is in practice saying is the way we
were going to win in 2024 was by filing motions
that would hopefully get to the Wisconsin
Supreme Court and the Wisconsin Supreme Court
would decide to give us the electoral votes.
Now, if you ask Charlie about it, he'll say,
no, no, no, no, no. I'm not saying we're going to
cheat. What I mean is Democrats will try to cheat.
And then we will have to go to the Supreme Court
of Wisconsin in order to get the rightful results,
which are that Trump or whoever will be the
winner, but who has a history of doing this
stuff. Remember, you look at 2020, they spent the
entire summer saying Democrats are going to try
to cheat. And we know they actually tried to. We
know that they had a number of these fraudulent
elector scams going in different states. We
know that they filed endless motions to try
to circumvent the actual will of the people.
This is actually very good news for Wisconsin,
where in Wisconsin you have women worried about
losing control over their own medical care,
who now have a better shot at retaining it thanks
to the change in the Wisconsin Supreme Court.
And of course, the fact that Charlie Kirk's big
concern is we were relying on that court in order
to try to win in 2024, tells you everything you
need to know about who and what they care about.
He's saying the quiet part out loud that Wisconsin
result could end up being really important.